millions of Americans are under a winter
storm watch as the first of back-to-back
storms is expected to hit the Northeast
this weekend the storm system could
bring heavy snow freezing rain ice and
Gusty winds Sunday into Monday the storm
will also mean more snow for Maine just
days after a system from the Rockies
pushed East and dumped half a feet of
snow in most parts of the state
meteorologist Kelly cast from our
partners at the weather channel has the
very latest Kelly good morning
good morning our very active weather
pattern continues from coast to coast
we've got a system now that's affecting
us across the Southern and Central
Plains bringing several inches of snow
to parts of Kansas back into New Mexico
as well and eventually bringing quite a
bit of snow for the interior sections of
the Northeast not so much for the
coastline though where we're still
waiting on that first measurable snow
this season we haven't gone yet in New
York City or Philadelphia we're going to
be on the Rainy side and plenty of rain
across the southeast as well here's the
way it plays out for today of course the
blue that is your snow it's heading for
the plaza in Kansas City as we go toward
the afternoon overnight tonight into
early tomorrow morning it heads for
Chicago where we could see anywhere from
a trace to a couple of inches of snow
Indianapolis we've got you in the blue
which means snow but that rain snow line
pretty far to the North to the South
there will be some showers possibly some
strong thunderstorms in south Georgia as
well as Southern Cal South Carolina and
then that system really gets going here
along the coastline producing some very
strong winds but the snow is mainly for
the interior not really bothering us
along the 95 Corridor except for maybe
Maine and Boston kind of getting
sideswiped by a little bit of snow on
its way out now the next system is
bigger it's going to be basically
bringing a lot more snow to the South
look at Texas Oklahoma and Arkansas the
European and the American models want to
give some pretty heavy snow there as
well as portions of New England and you
can watch the Weather Channel on cable
or live on your favorite TV streaming
devices Michelle
Kelly thank you